l'ordre du jour appelle la question
orale numéro 59 de monsieur christian
cambon à monsieur le ministre chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues
cette question a pour but d'attirer
l'attention du ministre chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche sur
le coût de plus en plus prohibitifs et
les disparités relatives aux péages pour
les usagers des autoroutes lors des
dernières vacances notamment
il n'a pas échappé en effet aux
automobilistes que les tarifs de péage
avait une nouvelle fois augmenté en
moyenne de 2 et demi en février dernier
alors que l'inflation n'a été qu'à peine
2 % une hausse encore plus importante
que celle de 2011 qui était alors de
2,24 pour cent ceci n'est évidemment pas
nouveau puisque en fait les tarifs ne
cesse d'évoluer plus vite que
l'inflation
le prix au kilomètre frôlé en 2012 les 8
centimes d'euros en moyenne
il était à 6 8 euros en 2005 ce service
public tend à devenir un luxe pour de
nombreux français qui sont tenus par
ailleurs d'utiliser leur auto mort leur
voiture nombre de nos concitoyens qu'ils
peuvent habiter dans les centres villes
à cause des prix élevés des logements
sont obligés d'emprunter ces
infrastructures autoroutières et y
consacre de ce fait une part de plus en
plus importante de leur budget or par
ces temps de crise il n'échappe à
personne
l'importance des dépenses en carburant
et en assurance qui ont beaucoup
augmenté et que doivent supporter les
automobilistes alors quand on se penche
un peu plus sur le problème les les
questions se multiplient selon les
trajets les prix des autoroutes varie de
plusieurs centimes au kilomètre une
différence qui au final peut se payer au
prix fort ainsi sur le tronçon de l'a 65
langon pau il faut payer 20 euros 70
pour parcourir 150 km alors que sur
l'a75 clermont ferrand béziers le trajet
de 331 km ne coûte
beast que 6 euros 70 donc on est
véritablement dans un rapport de 1 à
presque 4 les opérateurs de ces réseaux
qui ont certes des impératifs de
rentabilité fixe des péages de plus en
plus élevés cela conduit les
automobilistes à préférer les axes
secondaires qu'ils viennent charger
routes nationales route départementale
qui facilite leur trajet de manière
gratuite et ce dans la période que nous
connaissons ce cercle vicieux se vérifie
sur l'a65 l'une des plus chères
autoroutes de france qui a été ouverte
fin 1902 1010 le trafic escompté par le
concessionnaire était tellement faible
qu'il a dû lancer une véritable
opération commerciale on va bientôt
avoir des péages low cost cet été pour
attirer le trafic de proximité en effet
sur ce tronçon particulièrement cher et
coûteux les trajets de type
domicile-travail ont fait défaut aux
concessionnaires qui accuse une baisse
de 10% par rapport à l'an passé
les disparités de tarifs constatés sur
les autoroutes pour des trajets
équivalent ont bien évidemment l'art
d'agacer les automobilistes l'usager
doit faire parfois preuve de beaucoup
d'ingéniosité face à l'incohérence des
tarifs puisqu'il est parfois plus
coûteux et moins coûteux de sortir puis
de rentrer sur l'autoroute à différents
tronçons
plutôt que de faire le trajet en direct
de plus l'égalité des usagers devant le
service public n'est pas assurée puisque
dans certaines régions pour des raisons
certes historique que l'on connaît enfin
il convient de le noter c'est le cas de
la bretagne les autoroutes
elles sont totalement gratuites alors
depuis 2005 les sociétés
concessionnaires sont privés l'état a
concédé pour 15 milliards d'euros
quelques 8000 kilomètres de bitume au
géant du btp
celui ci a évidemment procéder à des
réductions d'effectifs à
l'automatisation des péages à
l'exploitation économique très
avantageuse des aires de service et en
même temps continue donc cette
augmentation des péages que j'ai évoqué
ces autoroutes sont devenus extrêmement
rentable alors qu'elles sont
financièrement amorties depuis longtemps
pour nombre d'entre elles et cela
n'empêche pas ces sociétés de continuer
à augmenter leurs tarifs et d'assurer
donc des profits
très confortable alors madame la
ministre monsieur misé transport peut-il
nous indiquer quelles initiatives votre
gouvernement souhaite prendre pour d'une
part obtenir des harmonisations
nécessaire de tarifs est par ailleurs
négocié avec les sociétés d'autoroutes
une modération de l'augmentation de ses
tarifs chaque année je vous en remercie
merci mon cher collègue madame la
ministre
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous avez
appelé l'attention du ministre délégué
en charge des transports de la mer et de
la pêche sur la hausse des tarifs de
péages autoroutiers votre question pose
l'aube allemand celle du modèle
économique des concessions d'autoroutes
en contrepartie de la réalisation de
l'infrastructure et de son exploitation
le concessionnaire perçoit des péages
auprès des usagers un contrat de
concession entre l'état et la société
d'autoroute fixe les évolutions
annuelles des tarifs les niveaux de ses
tarifs reflètent directement le montant
d'investissement qu'il a fallu mobiliser
pour réaliser l'infrastructure c'est la
raison pour laquelle il existe des
disparités entre les différentes
autoroutes
ainsi l'a 65 à laquelle vous avez fait
référence qui est une opération complexe
à des tarifs qui peuvent être jugés
élevés
en revanche la 75 n'a pas été concédées
en me le viaduc du bio mais a été
financée intégralement sur crédits
budgétaires le ministre délégué chargé
des transports souhaite saisir
l'occasion pour aborder de manière plus
générale la politique du gouvernement
vis-à-vis des concessionnaires
d'autoroutes la précédente majorité a
décidé en 2005 de céder l'intégralité
des parts détenues par l'état dans les
sociétés d'autoroutes pour un montant de
15 milliards d'euros que vous avez
rappelé cette décision était contestable
dans son principe et le privé la
puissance publique de ressources
régulières issus des dividendes de ces
sociétés soumettait le secteur aux
exigences et contraintes financières des
groupes prix
et contrôlant les sociétés
concessionnaires notamment s'agissant de
la rentabilité de leur investissement
mais cette décision a été prise
toutefois les contrats de concession été
conçu avec un objectif d' équilibre
les niveaux des péages doivent permettre
d'assurer une juste rémunération du
concessionaire en rapport avec ses
engagements financiers et le risque pris
cet objectif d'équilibré qu'il remplit
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas sûr il convient
de s'assurer du respect à échéance
régulière
je tiens à vous confirmer que le
gouvernement actuel s'y emploie le
ministre délégué en charge des
transports de la mer et de la pêche a
lui même rencontré à plusieurs reprises
les représentants des sociétés
concessionnaires en ce sens il s'agit en
effet d'une question majeure notamment
cette période de crise et le
gouvernement entend aujourd'hui assurée
une régulation juste de ce secteur
c'est la raison pour laquelle un
contrôle strict des hausses de tarifs
demandée par les sociétés
concessionnaires et désormais réalisés
pour qu'il n'y ait aucune augmentation a
justifié dit madame la ministre monsieur
cambon et madame la ministre
merci des éléments de réponse que vous
venez de nous donner jeu je prends comme
un élément positif le souhait du
gouvernement d'agir en matière de
régulation des tarifs avec l'observation
des conditions d'équilibré économique
partageons pas la même analyse sur le
mode de gestion je pense que la décision
de confier au secteur privé le réseau
autoroutier n'était pas une mauvaise
décision car l'état ne peut pas se
charger de tout et omnipotent en
revanche il est quand même nécessaire
effectivement d'obtenir de la part de
ces six découlent de ces sociétés
concessionnaires d'autoroutes
dérégulation vous parlez des disparités
et elles sont bien évidente est bien
connu quand il ya des ouvrages tels
viaduc de millau il est bien
compréhensible que l'usagé en haut on
porte les conséquences
en revanche j'observe que par exemple
sur l'autoroute du soleil fall autour du
sud est suivi le tour du soleil qui me
semble quand même un amorti depuis
quelques dizaines d'années on procède
toujours à des augmentations tout aussi
sensibles alors qu'il ya très très peu
d'ouvragés nouveau et de frais
d'entretien présentant un coût très
élevé
donc je pense effectivement que la
mesure que préconise votre collègue
ministre en sport est une bonne mesure
et il sera intéressant par exemple au
moment de la discussion budgétaire sur
le budget des transports que le ministre
nous donne le résultat de cette
concertation je vous remercie madame
alice